The order is gone I was betrayed
by the one I trusted most
I will not be imprisoned again
I hear you've been busy making
yourself the Empire's Most Wanted
thanks bud part of the job I guess
The Jedi is a threat. Not now that we have this.
as long as we fight
hope survives
Tell me cal kestis. Why
lead when they won't follow
why fight
when you can't
win
what is your next move
Jedi
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my Star Wars Jedi Survivor trailer video there's
a whole bunch of Easter eggs here I'll explain
what's going on with this fits in the timeline and
I know a lot of people have asked about calcuestas
showing up in live action like during the events
of the Mandalorian I'll explain what's going on
with that there have been a couple Easter eggs for
things from the Jedi Fallen order in Jedi Survivor
game already but I'll talk about what he was doing
during the events of the Obi-Wan Kenobi series
during the Star Wars Andor series The Original
Trilogy and during the events of the Mandalorian
series if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we're going to
get a new trailer for The Mandalorian season three
really soon as well too before the end of the year
in the Mandalorian season 3 episodes will come at
the beginning of March a lot of Cal kestus's story
later in the timeline also overlaps with ahsoka's
timeline as well so I'll explain her too later
in the video but the new trailers they release
reveal a bunch more about the actual story of the
game more than new changes they made it's meant to
take place five years after the events of Fallen
order so he's about 23 during the events of this
game it takes place the exact same year that the
Obi-Wan Kenobi episodes took place so like while
Obi-Wan Kenobi is saving young Leia orgata from
The Fortress inquisitorious the inquisitors Darth
Vader breaking that bottom area there just like
calcas did he's busy running around in the outer
rim in another part of the Galaxy during those
events I know there's always a lot of questions
about who knew what who knew where everybody
was during different parts of the timeline but
the idea is that the main Galaxy of Star Wars is
a vast a vast plays the Mandalorian for example
barely knew about Jedi characters at all when he
first took up the mission to take grogu back to
his people quote unquote to the other Jedi looking
for Luke Skywalker even though he didn't realize
it was Luke Skywalker he was looking for he
referred to them as ancient Sorcerers That's how
little he knew about the Jedi during the trailer
we get more clues about that other Jedi force
sensitive character that he finds in the back to
tank that looks like he's been stuck there for
years he finds another Jedi who survived Order
66 it also seems like he's meant to be the same
Jedi that he's fighting with the red lightsaber
later in the trailer there's this whole idea that
he's still trying to resuscitate the Jedi Order
going around finding other Force sensitive people
and helping people along the way one of the people
that the holocron leads him to is this person here
but it sounds like it's one of those situations
where he rescues his Force sensitive person who's
really bitter about what happened with Order 66
the emperor Darth Vader turning to the dark side
he says I will not be imprisoned again and
he sounds really dark so it sounds like they
might come to blows because of their differing
ideas about what they should actually do about
the Empire moving forward because you also see
this new character talking to the mercenaries
the calcasus was fighting in the other part of
the trailer when they refer to the Jedi giving
them problems so to speak like they're going
to continue to fight each other throughout the
game he holds up the device and says not as long
as we have this it seems like a tracking device
that helps him clock calcus around the Galaxy
Sierra junda comes back it looks like she's been
taking care of a new Jedi library or the remnants
of the old one it meant to look just like the old
Jedi Library we see him fighting a Wampa not on an
ice Planet inside an Imperial base finding similar
types of dark Trooper robots that we saw on the
Mandalorian series much later in the timeline I'm
assuming these Dark Trooper robots are different
from the ones that moth Gideon created because
I think his were supposed to build upon years of
Imperial engineering and research look they were
way more hardcore than the ones that calcestus was
fighting in this scene here we see him stopping
the Blaster shots in midair like kylo Ren the
other big change too isn't the big kylo Ren Easter
egg he has a cross-hill lightsaber just like
kylo Ren did except his doesn't look all janky
like kylo Ren's did the actual synopsis for the
story just raised during Star Wars Jedi Survivor
kalikestus is pushed further to the outer rim of
the Galaxy by the Empire Darth Vader the emperor
the inquisitors the game picks up five years after
Star Wars Jedi Fallen order notice the new scars
on his face like he's got a bunch of extra City
miles on him he crashes their spaceship during
the events of the game they say calcas considers
himself a Jedi Knight like he's a Padawan no
longer so at some point during those five years he
dubbed himself Jedi or sir junda did they also say
that during that five-year time Jump he's had
many sub subsequent run-ins with the Imperials
inquisitors since the end of Jedi Fallen order
he's still got bd1 there was another bd1 Droid
talk about Easter eggs for fallen order during
the live action series during book of Boba Fett
much later in the timeline because it's taking
place around the same time that the Mandalorian is
taking place they've already done the inquisitors
in live action and like I said this game in
particular takes place at the exact same time that
the Obi-Wan Kenobi episodes are taking place you
have to picture Darth Vader using the inquisitors
to go after calcast in much of the grand
Inquisitor Chagrin all of his attention shifts to
this Obi-Wan Kenobi person you just it's a picture
of Darth Vader being like okay we have history
I need to focus on Obi-Wan Kenobi right now I've
been obsessed with him for the past 10 years
since Revenge of the Sith he would definitely
be way more obsessed with Obi-Wan Kenobi than he
would be with calcas like he'd be pissed off about
what happened at the end of Jedi fall in order but
he's been way more pissed off about what happened
with Obi-Wan Kenobi and his scarring on Mustafar
remember early in the series when he almost caught
him again he said he was going to visit the same
torture on him that he himself self-suffered
during Revenge of the Sith meaning he planned on
burning Obi-Wan Kenobi like literally scarring
him and cutting his limbs off the synopsis goes on
to say that Cal will join forces with new allies
who ate him on his quest one of the first new
characters we see in the trailers is named Bodhi
Acuna who's a mercenary sea agenda obviously still
part of the game he saved her at the end of Fallen
order that's why she's still alive then we have a
couple new antagonists like we have this new Jedi
character that he rescues who seems like he falls
to Darkness and this is a creepy looking Senator
on Coruscant who seems like he's after him even
though it looks kind of like the grand Inquisitor
he's not meant to be the grand Inquisitor he's
supposed to be a brand new Senator character that
they're introducing for the game but the Big Ideas
at the end of that first game after he escapes The
Fortress inquisitorious with sir junda in the
holocron he tries to use that to start finding
other force-sensitive children around the Galaxy
and slowly rebuild the Jedi Order but because this
is taking place during the events of Obi-Wan
Kenobi we know a lot about what happens later
in the timeline because we don't see another real
Jedi Academy forming until Luke Skywalker create
it's his during the events of the Mandalorian
series we also found out that the planet that
that Jedi Academy is on is Asus which has a deep
history in Star Wars lore it goes all the way back
in the Legends Canon they explained that that
was the main planet that the Jedi Order moved
to the more modern Jedi Order when it Formed after
they left python which was the other planet they
visited in the Mandalorian Series where grogu
sent out the beacon in the force to basically
anybody that could hear it he was just lucky that
Luke Skywalker was the first person to respond
to the beacon because it wasn't just a beacon to
the Jedi it was a beacon to anyone who was force
sensitive and could detected there are also a lot
of people that we know about who survived who are
just waiting to come back in the live-action
projects who would have heard it too both bad
and good people a lot of that stuff they're saving
for the future live-action series like we'll get
into a lot of force lore during the Ahsoka Series
in particular those episodes will be coming right
after the Mandalorian season 3 probably sometime
around the summer like late summer maybe but
that'll take place during the same part of the
timeline or at least the main part of the series
there'll probably be some flashbacks during it
because I believe Hayden Christensen is also
supposed to show up during that but it either have
to be as a force ghost or it would be flashbacks
also talking about calcustus Ahsoka crossover
because we know more about what was happening with
Ahsoka during the rise of the empire this period
around the events of the Obi-Wan Kenobi series
during this period Ahsoka was basically hiding
out in the outer rim doing the same thing the
Obi-Wan Kenobi was doing before the events of his
series pick up just trying to hide his abilities
and not stick out both of them unsuccessfully like
both of them obviously came back to the force and
started helping people again what happened with
Ahsoka though is that bail Organa who is also the
person who got Obi-Wan Kenobi to start helping out
again too brought Ahsoka into the formal rebellion
and she became the fulcrum character and her main
job during this period of the rise of the empire
before the original trilogy was to serve as sort
of the point of communications between all the
different Rebel cells so she was very active
during the events of the original trilogy but
most of what she was doing was on the DL in the
outer rim away from the main part of the fighting
and it's probably going going to be the same thing
for calacastes and one of the reasons why they're
not introducing him already in live action is
probably because they don't want to spoil the
events of this game or any potential sequel games
but I do think that they will eventually use him
in live action it would be stupid not to he's
actually just a little bit younger than Ahsoka
like he'd be in his early 40s during the events of
the Mandalorian series that's around the same age
as Ahsoka she's like a little bit older than that
but still in her early to mid 40s probably one of
the other coolest things during the trailer though
is the dual wielding like dual building becomes a
big feature in the game and it doesn't have to be
you holding a regular double-bladed lightsaber and
breaking it apart it's just like two completely
different lightsabers that you get to use but if
there are any other Easter eggs or questions you
have about what's going on during the events of
this or how this crosses over with the other big
characters in the Star Wars Universe just write
it below in the comments we just got the Star
Wars bad batch season 2 trailer because that
series was starting at the beginning of January I
believe the next Mandalorian season 3 trailer is
supposed to come around Christmas time nice little
Christmas this gift that Star Wars is giving to
everyone of course we'll do a bunch more videos
about that as soon as they release more footage
so leave all your requests in the comments below
everyone click here for the Mandalorian Season
3 trailer and click here for my new Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 trailer video and easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!